Київ звинувачує сепаратистів у застосуванні мінометів
вздовж лінії розмежування останніми днями.
Кажуть, що їхні війська обстріляли з важкої зброї.
Ми є свідками ескалації конфлікту?
Спеціальна моніторингова місія протягом літніх місяців
спостерігала відносно малу кількість порушень режиму припинення вогню.
А  за останні чотири тижні ми побачили
стійке зростання кількості обстрілів
до чотиризначного числа в деякі дні
з кульмінацією цими вихідними,
коли були застосовані реактивні системи залпового вогню,
найбільш важке озброєння з найбільшим калібром,
яке застосовують обидві сторони конфлікту.
Це призвело до численних втрат серед цивільного населення,
які зафіксували наші спостерігачі за вихідні.
Чому так відбуваєтся?
Існує дві головні причини, чому бої тривають.
Одна з них - військово-технічна.
Це постійна присутність важкого озброєння -  мінометів,
танків, артилерії, включно із реактивними системами залпового вогню
по обидва боки лінії розмежування та на територіях,
де сторони дійшли згоди, що сили мають бути відведені на безпечну відстань.
Друга причина - близькість українських військових
та збройних формувань сепаратистів у багатьох місцях
у межах 10, 20, 30 метрів.
За таких обставин напруженість неминуча
і часто переростає у тривалі бої.
Триває дипломатичний процес із врегулювання конфлікту.
Але, враховуючи те, що ви мені щойно розповіли,
чи бачите ви якийсь прогрес
у політичному вирішенні конфлікту?
Дійсно, діалог триває на різних платформах.
Одна з них - платформа у Мінську,
де регулярно збираються усі сторони конфлікту,
усі зацікавлені сторони та підписанти Мінських угод
і намагаються знайти вирішення.
Сам діалог є важливим аспектом цього,
це відкритий канал, який допомагає уникнути подальшої ескалації.
Дійсно, складно домовитися про кроки,
які можуть бути втілені, але діалог не варто ігнорувати.
Це дуже важливо.
Зрештою, цей конфлікт можна вирішити лише шляхом діалогу.
Добре, ми знаємо про ескалацію, про яку ви щойно розповіли.
Я дивився на вашому сайті
там щодня повідомляється про сотні порушень
режиму припинення вогню.
Бойові позиції сепаратистів та української армії істотно
не змінилися протягом майже останніх трьох років.
Чи не перетворюється це на заморожений конфлікт на східному фланзі Європи?
Важливо усвідомити, що хоча контактна лінія сама по собі
останнім часом особливо не зсунулась,
сторони наблизилися одна до одної,
що призвело до дуже інтенсивних боїв у деяких місцях.
Конфлікт продовжує спричиняти чимало спалахів насильства,
як ви згадали, понад 300 тисяч порушень режиму припинення вогню
лише цього року, що означає,
що конфлікт далекий від замороженого,
він продовжує бути дуже інтенсивним, дуже непередбачуваним.
Якщо Мінські угоди не будуть реалізовані повністю,
конфлікт триватиме, він залишиться непередбачуваним
і спричинятиме подальші страждання мирного населення.
Ваша організація – одна з дуже небагатьох,
які мають доступ до людей по обидва боки лінії розмежування
і говорять з місцевими жителями,
які стають жертвами конфлікту, як ви згадали.
Як населення по обидва боки сприймає те, що відбувається?
Дійсно, наші неозброєні спостерігачі по обидва боки лінії розмежування
контактують з цивільним населенням,
яке дуже постраждало від конфлікту,
порівняно з озброєними формуваннями та українською армією.
Адже цивільні не мають захисту
вони не сидять в окопах, не мають охорони.
Діти ходять до шкіл, ведуть звичайне життя.
І вони часто страждають від постійного вогню
не в останню чергу через розміщення зброї в жилих кварталах,
які перетворюються потім на мішені.
Лише цього року місія підтвердила загибель
421 цивільного жителя,
що дорівнює кількості, зареєстрованій за такий же період торік.